[Music]
what's up
cam in chicago hey kim what's going on
hi dr john um thank you so much for
taking my call and i just will say that
i am blessed and my life is pretty
wonderful
is awesome told you james just kidding
hey thank you thank you for putting me
in my place i know that everyone's man
people are doing well right now
it's awesome so what's up how can i help
so my fiance and i are getting married
in october
okay and i'm calling because he
has had a very traumatic life um
and he's doing really well now and we're
really happy um
but i know that he never addressed any
of his traumas in counseling or anything
like that
so i'm kind of worried that his dramas
might manifest in some way in our
marriage
um is that something i should worry
about if no
how can i stop worrying and if yes how
can i help him
awesome question hey dude thanks for
loving that guy that's so good man when
y'all getting married
october 30th oh man so it's coming up
sooner rather than later
very cool okay so what kind of trauma
um everything under the sky so
i've heard you talk about the the ace
yeah that's right and i i looked at it
and i had him look at it with me and
i knew before showing it to him that he
was going to be high on it
because he's told me a lot of things but
what was his score
he's a 9 out of 10. whoa whoa
so everything under the sun literally
yeah
yeah wow and he's an amazing guy huh
oh my gosh yes he's he's he's incredible
so what would what would
if you were telling a story about him
what would you attribute
that connection between a nine out of
ten so for those who don't know the aces
score the adverse childhood experiences
scale
i think it was developed by nadine brick
harris uh just a
brilliant doctor i think she's the
attorney general now in california
i'm not attorney general i'm sorry the
chief medical officer of california
just an extraordinary um
practitioner researcher um what an
incredible heart she
she wrote an uh an awesome book called
the deepest well i recommend everybody
to read that book
um but she came up with the i think her
and her team come up with the adverse
childhood experiences skill it's a 10
question scale and it's simple
like were you in a house of divorce did
anybody in your home go to jail were you
ever abused
et cetera and man if you have a 9 out of
10
the predictive nature that you are going
to have some major challenges everything
from cancers to strokes to heart disease
to
um psychiatric issues etc is
statistically
through the roof right and then
now you're calling me telling me you're
gonna marry this guy and he's wonderful
so if you were telling the story how
would you attribute that what would you
attribute his
wonderful character in nature to
um well he always says that
he always says that him and his siblings
had a way of
looking at the adults in their lives and
like taking it as an anti-example
um so that was that's sort of what he
says
i i'm not really sure i mean
he met the lord
like last year and and got baptized um
so he has a spiritual foundation huge
yeah yeah
before that he didn't at all like he
didn't even believe in god
um but um
so that's i've noticed like a really big
change in him since then
okay so that's awesome how old are you
guys
um he's 29 and i'm 27. okay
wow 30. wow wow so
here's a couple of things so if if i'm
if i
love somebody who's got a 9 out of 10.
but it's someone who i'm married to one
of my best friends
i would look at that as highly
predictive
um but not prescriptive
and meaning not predetermined right
so there is a the recipe all the
ingredients are on the table for some
challenges downstream okay um
and it's something that i would highly
if i love this person
and i would highly recommend that um
that you create a life that would be
supportive and preventative
okay um sometimes trauma pops up in
weird ways like after your first kid
or after you get fired for the first
time or
there's a big catastrophic event
whatever that looks like
and sometimes people are just resilient
and strong and powerful and they've got
great people in their lives
and they've got a good spiritual
connection and they really take care of
their bodies and they sleep well
and so those of us who don't have a 9
out of 10 on the scale
what we end up doing is we flinch every
time they're in our presence
and 9 out of 10 is that's a lot
most of us um have somebody that we love
whose parents were divorced or who may
have experienced abuse or maybe
had um were sexually assaulted in
college or
were in a bad car wreck and what we do
is we
we anticipate in that person's life
and almost create a self-fulfilling
prophecy where we
touch like we walk around with velvet
gloves we don't want to ever disturb
and so we keep secrets or we don't want
to bother them so we hold on to stuff
or we're really struggling but we don't
want to burn them because they've had a
hard life and whatever and so we hold on
to this stuff
they sense that gap and then their
alarms kick back up the old alarms that
kept them alive does that make sense
and so what you don't want to do is to
create a self-fulfilling prophecy where
you
spend your life looking at this person
that you love through a magnifying glass
looking for evidence of trauma from
childhood emerging
thereby creating a relatively tense home
or you keep secrets from each other you
don't tell them everything you don't
lean into it
you don't demand that he be a great
partner and a great husband and somebody
who shows up and somebody who works hard
somebody doesn't get fired
all these things um
because the past becomes this excuse and
i loved the
the phrase your past is a context it's
not an excuse
right it gives you some idea as to why
you may have an over-inflamed body you
may not um
default to good sleep you may withdraw
when something gets heavy
you may have impulses towards anger or
frustration or addiction
but that doesn't give you an excuse to
then go down those paths does that make
sense
yeah so here's what's gonna be really
important for you guys
number one you gotta be really clear
with one another real clear
super honest and i would recommend i
don't know how you can get more honest i
would recommend
you guys having a default setting of
honesty
and connection now have you all gone
through any sort of premarital cancer
counseling
um we have met with our priest like a
couple of times but i was planning on
signing us up for like
actual yes counseling with a counselor
so
think of it as um this you've got a
family history of heart disease and
obesity
and what you're going to do at an early
age you're going to graduate college and
you're going to be
more attentive probably than most to not
eating foods out of packages
to eating healthy whole foods you're
going to be
intentional about moving your body and
exercising right so because you know
you've got this stuff
in you got the ingredients in the fridge
right and you don't ever want to just
start making it
same thing here so you can set up
preventative
counseling and what it is is just
learning tools he doesn't have a model
of what a healthy marriage looks like
and
you might not even either even though
you may not have a 10 or a 9 on the aces
score you may not have a good picture of
it either
so what y'all are going to do is you're
going to go learn new tools it's like
y'all taking a karate class
where you're going to learn to be ninjas
this is going to be learning how to be
married
right and it's not because you're broken
not because you're dysfunctional you're
just learning new tools
and then you're going to really
default to creating a life early on
where
sleep is important friends are important
exercise is important gratitude journals
where you all tell each other what
you're grateful for
um really being in tension with your
spiritual communities right
and then you you
not trying to protect him from
your heart your thoughts your needs your
fears your concerns does that make sense
yeah absolutely have you found yourself
doing that in your relationship
um i i don't know if i
i've been trying to protect him but i
would say that
i sometimes do like think
like oh is this a manifestation of his
trauma like
projecting that onto him kind of
um do you see how that becomes a
self-fulfilling loop
yeah yeah absolutely where you project
it and then he thinks uh no it's not and
now there's a gap
and then he goes back to some old habits
to try to solve that gap
to which then you go there's the trauma
and then the loop just gets bigger and
starts spinning faster and faster
right and so it's you trusting
when you ask him are you doing okay and
he goes i'm doing awesome
that you go great and you don't start
reading into that
right or if you he says i'm doing
awesome and then you can then say
you haven't come to bed the last three
nights and you've been sleeping on the
couch and you're playing a lot of video
games
and since we have been to counseling and
we know that withdrawal is one of the
things that sends you down a tough path
you're starting i feel you starting to
withdraw from me right and that he can
not respond in anger you leave me look
but he says you're right i'm withdrawing
and then y'all can be right in the
middle of it does that make sense
yeah that way there's no projection
there's you being honest there's he
being honest and you all are just in it
and moving on
yeah that makes sense and to his credit
like
i should have said this earlier but he
really has done like a lot of work on
himself like
trying to cultivate a lot of like
awareness of what he does
and um you know sort of his
his toxic thought patterns wow
and i since this calls about you really
i know you're calling about him but
really calls about you
um yeah he sounds like he you can't have
a 9 out of 10 a score and just
dust your hands and shake it off and be
like hey cool i'm doing great
right everything so he clearly has put
in a lot of work
which is to his credit um don't
don't superimpose your fears on him
be honest with him put your fears out on
the table and say hey i would get
nervous about this stuff
i want to know what some of your toxic
thought patterns are and some of your
default settings are so that
if i see them i'd love to be able to put
them on the table and say hey this is
making me nervous or making me scared
it's when you feel nervous and scared
and you decide oh i can't bring this up
that's the recipe for disaster or you
bring it up and he says
no it's not then that's a recipe for
disaster right
it doesn't sound like that's the
trajectory y'all are on i want you to
have peace going into this and you all
do the work up front when everybody's
healthy everybody's doing
good it's like going to the gym when you
feel great not waiting until you have uh
the flu to start a workout program but
what a great heart i'm so excited for
you guys congratulations on getting
married
after your wedding shoot me a note that
just says hey we got married
all is awesome here in chicago and cam
we will be rooting for you guys
and for everybody listening two big
important takeaways
if you've got divorce in your life if
you've got
i'm filling in the blank here um family
history of addiction of heart disease of
whatever of mental health challenges
and you're doing okay you're doing well
set up a life while you're doing well
that will buffer for when the hard
seasons come right
it's like building your house on a good
strong firm foundation so
that when the hurricanes come and they
will come
it doesn't blow over right so you've got
a strong foundation for when some of
these things
come back right ah good for you guys uh
all right let's go to
jared in iowa oh oh i just said two
things that was one
the second thing is don't project don't
project your fears onto your partner
it it'll melt them it'll melt them